[Music]
Moe the bartender was just you doing an
impression of Al Pacino right I
yeah I was going to play and at the time
in LA I was playing drug dealer and I
was doing a very bad early Pacino like
from Dog Day Afternoon I'm dying here
everybody's coming down on the sound I
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
here and I did that voice and said what
we wanted gravel it was based on red you
guys used to love a red didn't ya love
red red the BART - exactly right it's on
that yeah so red was like this right now
yeah every month if you make Pacino
gravely you get motor bartender
well chief Wiggum is kind of a weird
Edward G Robinson man a nine-time Abu is
just the best I could do of what I heard
of kids growing up were Indian and and
the guy who worked at the 7-eleven you
mean in Los Angeles snake in his snake
this dude is a guy I went to college
with he was a guy who would take a lot
of drugs and would report to you unasked
what he was experiencing on the drug
trip and he would come up and go oh dude
I'm totally seeing colors now and like
it was after image when I move my hand
and I could not care less Comic Book Guy
wish the guy lived next door to me
freshman year all right Lou the cop on
the sentence fairly obscure but I like
them right it's just a bad Stallone
impression Rocky's ism or your what so
you kind of a tobacco consumer and it
became you know a black cop on The
Simpsons 30 years of the Simpsons I
think I have done every voice I can
possibly do every sound I can make is a
human being a baby